hey good to see you sir congratulations
on this
epic masterpiece it's beautiful man
thank you so much yes yeah i'm curious
what is the biggest lesson you've been
able to take away from the long
and winding road of trying to get this
made into a film
well when i started writing the song
pastiencia ife which means patience and
faith
in 2004 i didn't realize they would be
the words to live by
as we spent our 20s writing the stage
version of heights
and our 30s uh getting that story from
the stage to the big screen
uh i'm 41 years old now uh it was a
13-year journey
and and and i wouldn't trade any of it
that's the really crazy part i think
every you know
when kiara and i finally revisited this
material we're
we're better writers than we were uh
when we wrote the first version i think
she did a brilliant job of adapting the
screenplay
and even the the pandemic delay you know
we filmed this in the summer of 2019
we were supposed to come out in the
summer of 2020 we had to wait a year
and it is such a time capsule of the joy
of community of hugging
in the streets and dancing and kissing
and
um and being in community together which
is we all need a reminder in how to
do that now and so i'm so grateful for
it
well i do think that you know with
everyone around the world watching this
when we do get a chance to be around
each other again it's going to be
singing and dancing
because of this movie well thanks
yourself
primarily that now coming from you know
the world of theater you know
the importance of collaboration and
trust
what was it like to give over this you
know this piece that you
have said was your way in um to trusting
john chu with
your with this piece and trusting his
vision for it
yeah i think the the overwhelming
feeling kiara and i had when we met
john for the first time was he
understands this from a
lived experienced place now he's not
latino
but he is first generation like we are
his dad made
miracles happen to create a restaurant
uh that was successful you know he
always says i grew up in a chinese
restaurant
um and when you when you grow up and
your parents sort of
make a way where there is no way and
then you have the
much scarier path to you know when
you're john reaching for a video camera
if you're me
saying i want to musical theater um
it's it's he was able to he he really
intrinsically understands the nuance of
the burden and um and honor of the
sacrifices
your parents make on your behalf and and
navigating that
and also living your own life and living
your own dreams and i think that's
something a lot of the characters
in our in our story um really kind of
struggle with and engage with and john
knew that in on a cellular level within
himself
yes and lastly before we go i'm curious
whose reaction is most important for you
when you are
you know unveiling a work um
i try not to think about that while i'm
writing i'm just trying to make myself
laugh or make myself cry or make kiara
laugh or make your yara cry my co-writer
um but i i do have to say with this
movie
um this is a love letter to our
neighborhood and we want
our neighborhood to be proud of it and
to feel seen
um because we we filmed on location we
did our best
to make the neighborhood feel included
at every step of the journey of this
um and and i'm so excited uh for for
them
i'm excited for that premiere on 175th
street uh when we when we get to watch
it with the community
it's going gonna be amazing i wish i
could be there man all right thank you
so much for your time
congratulations again thank you carlos
you